allez un petit truc qui est fou aux
États-Unis regardez ils mettent du
plastique tout autour un espèce de grand
film plastique autour des panneaux
autour de plein truc pour que vous
puissiez venir poser vos autocollants et
l'idée c'est de se dire une fois que les
événements sont terminés on peut venir
retirer et ça abîme pas tout ce qui va
être voyez ici c'est un parcmètre pour
autant c'est fou ça avait pas plus ils
viennent vous mettre du plastique ça
reste hyper polluant tout ça pour
sauvegarder le matériel mais c'est du
plastique voilà je trouve ça un peu
dingue c'est les US c'est comme ça il y
a des choses un peu bizarre parfois mais
voyez il y en a partout partout dans la
ville ici je suis à austino Texas et ils
se font plaisir vous voyez une fois que
c'est fini tac on enlève tout ça et hop
c'est propre pas de problème